[Musique]
la politique c'est l'art de l'exécution
le président est incapable d'exécuter
c'est à dire faire des discours ça il a
l'habitude de le faire et on connaît
d'ailleurs la rhétorique c'est toujours
la même il commence par un mea culpa
j'ai sans doute eu des maladresses j'ai
pu blesser certaines personnes mais en
fait j'ai réformé mais les français
n'ont pas compris ce discours là nous le
sert à chaque fois simplement où on en
est la réforme des retraites
il remet sur la table on est trois ans
pour rien nous avait promis un nouveau
chemin nous avait promis de se
réinventer en est chez nous n'avons rien
de tout cela puisque d'abord sur le plan
gouvernemental c'est la même équipe qui
sera en responsabilité elle est
quasiment reconduite dans son
intégralité
on n'a pas non plus perçue dans cette
interview les lignes de ce que serait
cette deuxième partie du quinquennat ce
que les français attendent c'est un
changement de cap
on voit aujourd'hui que les indicateurs
économiques ne sont pas bons sur la
dette sur la croissance si on se compare
par rapport aux autres pays européens
si on regarde les chiffres des
délinquants si on regarde ce en matière
d'immigration et donc le bilan de ces
trois années pardon mais il n'est pas
bon est ce que les républicains nous
avons confiance en ce gouvernement qui
va être l'exécutant de la politique
macro nien
la réponse est non ce n'est pas une
question de personnes c'est une question
d'idées de projets moi je considère
aujourd'hui que nous n'avons pas le même
projet qu'emmanuel mac je dis aux
français aujourd'hui
ne vous laissez pas berner par les mots
ni par les discours ça fait trois ans
qu'on la subit quelle marge de manoeuvre
il va avoir face à une majorité en
marche qui vient de la gauche il est
face à un gouvernement qui est un
gouvernement ni de droite ni de gauche
qui incarne en même temps présidentiel
et c'est ça sa difficulté majeure
aujourd'hui c'est d'être enfermé dans un
en même temps présidentiel qui risque de
paralyser l'action et c'est là où on
jugera donc sur les actes et sur les
régions
il a dans son discours de politique
générale hier à l'assemblée
quelque part
dresser en creux un constat assez
accablant de ce qu'ont été les trois
années du maquereau nice peut regretter
que dans l'intervention du président de
la république d'hier pas un mot sur le
régalien
alors que comme dans le secteur
économique le bilan de monsieur mâcon
est catastrophique sur le plan de la
sécurité
il est absolument nécessaire que le
gouvernement montre combien l'autorité
de l'état est une chose que l'on ne
discute pas et il ya des gens en france
des activistes qui veulent dénoncer les
violences policières
ça aussi c'est une inversion de valeur
ça aussi c'est une inversion de
responsabilité fait responsables des
violences ne sont pas les policiers
emmanuel macron n'a pas dit un mot de
l'insécurité qui pèse sur les français
[Musique]